you get mistaken a lot for actor josh
duhamel
okay in fact today i was pretty sure we
booked josh dumel we were excited
and then that's why i'm here again i'm
here to promote
something something on
that's netflix i'm here isn't it
stunning it's stunning how much he looks
like josh dumoul
yeah here's a side-by-side picture of
the two of them
i don't even know i can't tell which one
is you you know he did
i think though dumel is like the large
version and he's the
medium version because dumel is a big
tall man yeah
now this is this is true i i can vouch i
tell you
you know he did my um he
god bless him he he did the uh my family
christmas card
he posed he posed with my family for
and uh we sent it out as my yeah is that
true that's absolutely wait so you got
josh dumel to pose with your wife and
kids
and you're not in the picture yeah no i
have it on my phone i'm gonna show it to
you
i we so
for years i've been hearing this goes
way back early 2000 like i've been
hearing you know this guy josh duhamel
was like no he said you guys look a lot
alike you know and we had friends in
common
and then i'd get mistaken for him and uh
my wife just would love that she'd just
needle me you know like oh
it's just doable you know and i'd be
like often
um she loved it though
yeah and then i i just we had friends at
common so i knew he often
we had this mutual thing we got mistaken
for one another
so we're at this uh we're out at dodger
stadium
and um and for a charity event that
clayton kershaw was putting on
my buddy aj ellis at the time was
playing for the dodgers there's a lot of
names involved
let me you want me to tell you about my
all the people the college professor
i'll pay you not to thank you so anyway
help me out stay on track i'm right here
i'm right here with you
you're playing this charity event we're
dodgers and there he is
josh dewamel yes and we've never met and
as soon as we see each other
just laughter just laughter just years
of his what we both
and anyway uh long story short if that's
still possible
i say hey dude my family whole family's
here
would you take a picture with them and
uh he
uh very kindly obliged and it was
wonderful
but we sent this out as happy holidays
from all the elephants and josh
here's the picture here where am i
putting it look at that so
all i know is that uh right around uh
the holidays my brother calls me
uh from my mom's place he says i'm here
at mom's
and your christmas card's on the
refrigerator uh with all the holiday
cards and
mom saying don't doesn't don't they lo
everyone look great
and my my brother says mom you know
that's not tim right
she's like what are you talking about or
whatever she goes that's not
tim in the card your mom didn't choose
that's an actor named josh
dewamel
and i swear to you according to my
brother he said mom
lit peeks in and goes i thought he
looked taller
i sent that we we now extend exchange
holiday cards he's on the holiday card
mailing list he got a card that year
from us and i got a card from him and
the only difference was is
he was in both cards yeah he's yeah so
you know what he can do no wrong as far
as i'm concerned everyone should watch
his show
on netflix yeah it's like a superhero
thing i think it's great yeah
[Laughter]
and he'll be watching your show the
guest starring timothy guess he could
come on and be a host
yeah you're not taking that mug with you
we're hanging on to those those are
collector's items